- [Voiceover] Let's get
some practice comparing
and computing rates.
So they tell us the pet
store has three fish tanks,
each holding a different volume of water
and a different number of fish.
So Tank A has five fish, and
it has 40 liters of water,
Tank B, 12 fish, 100 liters of water,
and Tank C, 23 fish, and
it has 180 liters of water.
Order the tanks by volume per fish
from least to greatest.
So let's think about what volume per fish,
and we could think about this
as volume divided by fish.
Volume per fish.
All right, so here for Tank A,
it's going to be 40 liters
for every five fish.
40 for every five fish, and let's see,
40 over five is eight,
so you have eight liters per fish,
is the rate at which they
have to add water per fish
for Tank A.
Now, Tank B, you have 100 liters
for 12 fish,
so what is this going to be?
This is going to be, 12
goes into 100 eight times,
so eight times 12 is 96, and
then you have four left over.
So this is going to be eight and 4/12,
or eight and 1/3 liters per fish.
And all I did is I converted
this improper fraction,
100 over 12, to a mixed
number, and I simplified it.
12 goes into 100 eight times
with a remainder of four,
so it's eight and 4/12,
which is the same thing as eight and 1/3.
And then finally in Tank C,
I have 180 liters
for 23 fish.
So what is this going to be?
23 goes into 180. Let me
try to calculate this.
23 goes into 180, it looks like it's going
to be less than nine times.
Is it eight times?
Eight times, no, not eight times.
Let's see, seven times.
Seven times three is 21,
seven times two is 14,
plus two is 16.
When you subtract you
get a remainder of 19.
So this is going to be seven
with a remainder of 19,
or you could say this is seven
and 19/23 liters
per fish.
So which one has,
we're going to order the
tanks by volume per fish,
from least to greatest,
so Tank B has the largest volume per fish,
has eight and 1/3 liters per fish,
so this is in first place.
And then Tank A is in second place.
Tank A is in second place.
And then Tank C is in third place.
Oh, actually we wanna go
from least to greatest,
so this is, let me write it this way.
This is Tank C is the least,
and Tank A is the greatest.
So we really have to
swap this order around.
Now, I just copied and pasted this
from the Khan Academy exercises.
Let me actually bring
the actual exercise up,
and I can rearrange it.
C was the least,
and B was the most,
and we check our answer
and we got it right.